en otro vídeo hablamos sobre la idea de
potencias de diez vimos que sí tenemos
diez a la primera potencia significa que
sólo vamos a tener un 10 si tenemos 10 a
la segunda potencia significa que
tenemos 2 10 es que es 10 x 10 lo que es
igual a 100 si tenemos 10 a la tercera
potencia quiere decir que tenemos 3 10
es que se multiplican y que es igual a
1000 que es lo mismo que tener un 1
seguido por 3 ceros aquí pueden notar un
patrón pero lo que vamos a hacer en este
vídeo es pensar en los patrones que
surgen al multiplicar y dividir cosas
arbitrarias con potencias de 10
comencemos con un número
digamos que comenzamos con 2.3 y primero
lo multiplicamos por 10 a la primera
potencia esto es lo mismo que
multiplicar por 10 y ya hemos visto que
si multiplicamos por 10 vamos a
desplazar todos los dígitos una posición
a la izquierda el 2 que estaba en la
posición de las unidades lo desplazamos
a la posición de las decenas
el 3 que estaba en la posición de las
décimas ahora lo desplazamos a la
posición de las unidades esto es igual a
23 siempre es bueno verificar lo que
hacemos este 2 al multiplicarlo por 10 a
20 por lo que tiene sentido que 2.3
multiplicado por 10 sea 23 continuemos
ahora multipliquemos 2.31 por 10 a la
primera potencia que es 10 sino por 10 a
la segunda potencia a que será igual
esto pausa en el vídeo y traten de
resolverlo ya sabemos que 10 a la
segunda potencia es igual a 100 y si
multiplicamos por 100 o por 10 dos veces
vamos a desplazar los dígitos dos
posiciones a la izquierda
voy a dibujar algunas posiciones aquí lo
que está en la posición de las unidades
se desplaza a la posición de las
centenas y lo que está en la posición de
las décimas se desplaza a la posición de
las decenas ahora este 2 representa dos
centenas y estas tres décimas ahora
representan tres decenas y ahora tenemos
cero
y si volvemos a multiplicar por 10 es
decir 2.3 por 10 a la tercera potencia
vamos a desplazar todo tres posiciones a
la izquierda 10 a la tercera potencia es
lo mismo que multiplicar por mil al
multiplicar 2.3 por 10 a la tercera
potencia el 2 se desplaza tres
posiciones a la izquierda por lo que
pasa de 2 a 2 mil lo que tiene sentido
esto es 2000 las tres décimas se
desplazan tres lugares a la izquierda
por lo que se convierten en tres
centenas y ahora hay cero decenas y cero
unidades el patrón que están viendo es
que al multiplicar un número por diez a
alguna potencia simplemente desplazamos
los dígitos a la izquierda el mismo
número de posiciones que la potencia y
si dividimos entre una potencia de 10 va
a ocurrir lo mismo solo que ahora se
desplazan las posiciones de los dígitos
a la derecha por ejemplo a que es igual
2.3 dividido entre 10 a la primera
potencia pausa en el vídeo y traten de
verlo 10 a la primera potencia es lo
mismo que 10 y cuando dividimos entre 10
todos los dígitos se desplazan una
posición a la derecha el 2 se desplaza a
la posición de las décimas y el 13
desplaza a la posición de las centésimas
esto es igual a 0.23 el 2 está en las
décimas y el 3 en las centésimas podemos
seguir con esto qué pasa si dividimos
dos puntos 3 entre 10 a la segunda
potencia pausa en el vídeo y traten de
calcular a que es igual esto en esta
situación vamos a desplazar todos los
dígitos dos posiciones a la derecha
vamos a indicar las posiciones aquí
estas son las unidades estas las décimas
estas las centésimas y estas las
milésimas lo que está en la posición de
las unidades no se desplaza a las
décimas sino que se desplaza a la
posición de las centésimas que no
alcanzamos a ver aquí pero que estarían
acá el dos va a estar acá y el 3 se
desplaza tres posiciones a la derecha
por lo que termina aquí
y tenemos 0 unidades y 0 décimas
nuevamente es probable que vean el
patrón aquí cualquiera que sea el
exponente si dividimos un número entre
10 a esa potencia vamos a desplazar los
dígitos la misma cantidad de posiciones
que ese exponente a la derecha